whenever you listen to the radio watch
tv or browse the internet you are
bombarded with crises of all types while
these crises political health social
play out on a global stage many of us
struggle with crisis situations of our
own today i look forward to our
discussion of crisis communication i'm
matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
i am so excited to be joined by david
demarist who is a lecturer of management
at the gsb
prior to the gsb david served as white
house communications director for
president george h.w bush and was a
member of the white house senior staff
next david served as executive vice
president and director of corporate
communications at bank of america and
then as executive vice president for
corporate relations and brand management
at visa international
later he became stanford's vice
president for public affairs and oversaw
communications and government relations
and events
beyond teaching at the gsb david is
finishing his book about what life is
like working in the white house welcome
david hey thanks matt it's great to be
with you this is going to be fun there's
so much for us to discuss should we get
started you bet
so question one when it comes to crises
you've had to deal with a few for sure
can you highlight one or two that you've
dealt with and any learnings that have
come from those experiences
uh well sure um
one day i came into the office and one
of my staff told me that we had due to a
data processing center
foul up that we had lost 1.2 million
automatic credits and automatic deposits
that's a lot of transactions to lose
and they roll in california
and
it meant that people's mortgage payments
weren't going to happen it meant that
their payroll their paycheck didn't get
deposited things like that it meant that
a lot of insufficient funds checks might
be going out and it was a incredible
mess
this was a formula for a whole lot of
very angry customers sure well what what
we were able to do was to disaggregate
what were the accounts that
might have been
more easily
remediated
by virtue of if somebody had a bank of
america account for their payroll
deposit and a bank of america account
for their mortgage payment
we could intercept that transaction in
between and fix it what it meant was
that we could get those transactions
down to a manageable level of the ones
that we really couldn't address in the
short term so by the end of the day we
had narrowed it down to about 69 000
uh insufficient funds notices that were
going to go out so that meant that our
focus could be okay what are we going to
do about those people
and come up with a remedy for them
that made sense and get our apology
notes out to them and so forth it told
me that you need to be able to
disaggregate the problem into its
component parts and deal with the parts
that are most uh critical
[Music]
the second uh
crisis i would put out there was that
at stanford we had a laptop that was
stolen and it contained a lot of
employee personal data
like thousands of employees personal
data
we didn't know if it was stolen from the
data or if it was just stolen because it
was a laptop
that didn't really matter
by the time we figured out what was on
the computer
we knew that we had to do a public
announcement to as a notification
but it was already late in the day on
friday not the time when you want to do
a public announcement people think
you're trying to hide the information
so our choice really was to do it then
or do it monday
also on monday we'd have all the systems
in place the
toll-free number uh what we're going to
do about identity theft and things like
that
we made the choice to go on friday at 6
pm and we did that because we felt that
people's trust in us
trumped
the efficiency of waiting until monday
that if anyone had their identity stolen
over the weekend and they found out that
we knew about it about this breach but
we didn't talk to them about it when we
knew about it
that would be a violation of the trust
and we it came down to trust beats
efficiency
and in our communication we told people
that we won't have the toll-free number
set up until monday
we won't have the
identity theft remediation set up until
monday but we felt it was important to
get this information out as soon as we
knew what the circumstance was because
we didn't want to risk someone not being
able to take an action on their own to
try to protect themselves
thank you for sharing those two i hear
two lessons that you learned one is
in a big complicated crisis it's it's to
your advantage to break it down into its
constituents parts and it sounds like
having a platform and technology that
can help you doesn't hurt in that
situation and then the other piece is to
to know your values that you as an
organization have and and really
challenge yourself to live by those
values and and that must help be a
guiding light
yeah you know i think too many
organizations haven't spent enough time
really thinking about what would they do
in a circumstance
that called upon them to act
without
knowing all of the details of the
situation
the pressure to act can be intense
and that's why value knowing your values
is so important because it gives you a
a beacon that can inform how you're
going to prioritize uh your actions
so let me ask you the second question
when communicating about a crisis what
are some best practices to keep in mind
so when you're actually sending the
message out
yeah i think the the key here
is that a
you got to know what you don't know
so you have to have kind of a catalog of
information that you would like to know
but maybe you don't know and how
important is that information which
leads to don't speculate people
speculate as to what might be the case
not necessarily what is the case
and then you mentioned it earlier know
your organization's values and be guided
by them
you know companies and organizations
that have a solid sense of who they are
and what they stand for they will be
able to navigate a crisis much more
effectively than those companies or
organizations that don't and i even tell
my students this uh matt that if you
know as a person what your values are in
this crazy turbulent world that we live
in you'll be able to navigate it a lot
better than to always be situational
finally
if there's a necessity for apology and
often there is
that apology has to be timely it's got
to show true regret the organization has
to take real responsibility in other
words ownership and if possible provide
a remedy and that's what we did in the
case of the stolen laptop we did provide
a remedy to people which was identity
protection and we did that quickly
thank you so i know you have some very
specific ways of thinking about audience
engagement uh can you share what this
looks like from your perspective
yeah i think that if if we take stanford
as an example uh but it it applies to
pretty much any organization
uh all organizations have multiple
constituencies so in stanford's case as
you well know we have students we have
faculty we have donors we have alumni we
have the federal government who you know
supplies us with a billion dollars of
research every year uh research funding
we have the local community and so forth
and so
every organization has multiple
constituencies that care about
how the organization interacts with them
some more than others so
part of effective crisis management is
have is to have your finger on the pulse
of each one of those constituencies and
what elements of the crisis are going to
be germane to which constituency to a
greater or lesser degree
so you start to have kind of a a
stakeholder map in a sense
and then
that allows you to know what their
concerns what their fears are what their
uh what their anger quotient might be if
uh something has affected them you know
very directly
and then the next step is to go where
they are
you've got to you can't kind of sit back
and wait then wait for them to come to
you you have to go to them and basically
listen to them
ask for their guidance as to what it is
that is of concern to them and how
should you
how how can they help you meet their
concerns so it's a much more proactive
engagement with stakeholders than to
simply tell people what you're doing and
then you know hope that hope for the
best
right
so your audience engagement approach uh
is similar to what we've talked about
prior on this podcast which is really
know your audiences and understand what
it is that's important to them you're
doing this very proactively in case
something
bad happens you you know and you're
engaged with them prior and and i also
heard you say be very mindful of the
different methodologies tools and
modalities with which you can connect to
them and leverage those so you can get
your messages out quickly um and
proactively i need to figure out how i
can affect the anger quotient of some of
the people that i live with in my house
i'd like to reduce it a little bit so
you got me thinking about that for sure
we've talked about we've talked about
knowing your values knowing your
corporate values we've talked about
knowing your audience and engaging them
what are other things people can do
proactively to prepare for a crisis that
might arise
well i'd say two things one
there are certain
crises that happen that are impossible
to foresee
in very concrete terms and people will
you know people aren't going to blame
stanford if there's an earthquake what
they will blame stanford for is if we
were not prepared knowing that we're in
an earthquake zone
when i think about how people think
about crises
i would i would suggest that they do an
inventory of what are the worst things
that can happen
and are we prepared for those things
that's kind of part one
part two is don't drink the kool-aid
a lot of people in organizations
particularly leadership in organizations
fall into the trap of having an
organizational bias in favor of their
organization oh we would never do that
that is a dangerous trap we have to
really get to the facts of this case not
just what our preconceived notions are
about how good our organization is
so you have to put your shoes and put
yourself in the shoes of someone who
might have an alternative uh view of
your organization
and that takes a little bit of hard
thinking because you know i lo i love
working for stanford and you know i've
been there 16 years
and it would be easy to think oh well
stanford would never do this or never do
that well you've got to be able to put
yourself in the shoes of somebody who
might not think the way i do about the
university or about my organization
sometimes you got to think like an
adversary or you have to think like a
reporter and get yourself out of your
comfort zone and think in ways that a
critic would think
very useful uh ideas and in fact the the
last idea about seeing
the situation from somebody else's
perspective echoes something bob sutton
shared on our podcast in terms of team
meetings and group decision making it
can always benefit to have
that other perspective and as you said
to make sure that we're not drinking the
kool-aid uh and i and i think reflecting
on what could go wrong while maybe
depressing and concerning is is a great
thing to do again in the name of being
proactive in preparation i'd like to
change the topic a little bit you've
spent a lot of your life in the
political world and you even teach a
course on political communication
looking at our current political
landscape what advice do you have for
people who are trying to push a
political agenda that is important to
them such as equity energy employment
what advice might you have
yeah we we live in a very uh
in a remarkably polarized environment
politically
and it is
very difficult to
you know have conversations
metaphorically across the aisle
i think it's a tough arena to navigate
within but i think if you're going to be
successful in trying to expand support
for
your cause or your
agenda
you have to refrain from the temptation
of being too judgmental about those who
might not buy into what you're trying to
sell
and try to understand why
at a deeper level what's their concern
about it and then make your case on
their terms not yours
you know you've got to be thoughtful
about what avenue you can take to try to
break through some of perhaps a rigidity
of view on the other side
but
coming at it from a different angle
might be a little bit more persuasive
than simply jumping up and down and
saying you're the devil incarnate right
um
the second half of that is you know for
your supporters
it's really about moving them from just
being
supportive to action
and that means communicating urgency and
how you communicate urgency is to make
sure that they see the present day
merits
of dealing with a particular problem
i i really like how you separate those
two points the thing that really
resonated with me was the the notion
initially of
framing your point in the language and
the approach that the people you're
trying to convince
are taking uh rather than it's my idea
and you should see the world the way i
do try to appreciate the way the other
people see the the world and and put
your communication in that perspective
and then the second part there this
notion of urgency and driving action a
lot of us feel that hey if i just share
the information that it's inherent and
intuitive that action should follow but
building that sense of urgency providing
a pathway to action becomes very
important
yeah
you know i remember back at my bank of
america days the cfo
was the person that i ultimately
reported to
and when i would talk to him about
reputation management he'd kind of glaze
over
and because i wasn't talking in a
language that he could really relate to
so i changed my language to be one about
risk management that was a concept that
he was very familiar with
and that enabled me to
have more fruitful conversations with
him about the steps that we needed to
take when we had to deal with
reputational risk business risk
financial risk and so forth
that last point you made about the
linguistics of it leads me to my next
question which i know you and i share is
something that we we are passionate
about and concerned with and teach about
and that is the language you use and and
the rhetoric involved in communication
what thoughts do you have of the
importance of our words and does
anything change as a result of our
communicating virtually rather than in
person
yeah those are those are really two
great questions i'm i love
language one of the modules in my class
is about language and rhetoric
you know when when you think about
language and
you look at some you know i don't mean
to get too esoteric here but the word
strategy for example comes from the
greek word strategos which means a
general
and the word tactics comes from the
greek tactos which means arranged in
order
the difference between strategy and
tactics then you know you kind of can
bring to life by talking about their
derivation
so
you know language is really what we use
to provide information to make an
argument to motivate behavior paint a
picture tell a story
you know all of those things are
essential to bringing your issue to life
and in other words first building an
understanding of one's agenda
you know i i think generally speaking
those principles are applicable to the
virtual world
crisis management is is indeed much more
complicated with the advent of social
media we all know that
speed is essential because social media
you know creates a
narrative so quickly
that people can mobilize faster bad news
travels faster than it used to
misinformation can spread like wildfire
you have to understand
you know the platforms that we are all
living with and you've got to
communicate to people in those spheres
you know it used to be a rule that kind
of a communications rule that never
repeat the accusation that's made
against you yeah because that just
reinforces the accusation
well in the in the virtual world
if you have an answer to an accusation
and you don't put the accusation in your
talking points or your your faqs or
whatever
somebody searching for
that
issue
will never find your answer
so
you know just using the right words so
that they are optimized for search
you know we have to be sophisticated and
know that people are going to go to the
web to find out information about a
particular issue or crisis and you've
got to use the language that they would
likely use in their search and so it's
little things like that that i think can
help us deal with crisis management in
the virtual world absolutely and uh the
notion of really thinking about
wording and and the exact language you
use is so powerful most people focus on
here's what i want to get across but if
you spend just a little extra time of
thinking about how do you use certain
words to help you get that information
across it can be incredibly powerful i
joke with people i have a 17 year old
son he's just gotten his driver's
license he wants a car you cannot today
david buy a used car you can buy a
certified previously owned vehicle but
you can't buy a used car it's the same
car but calling it a certified
previously owned makes it sound
different and better and they can charge
more for it so this notion of choosing
language wisely to help you further your
goal i think is really important and i i
know you and i both share that and and i
hadn't thought about
how how
detailed you have to get in your
thinking when it comes to the virtual
world and how people actually search for
the things that you're putting out there
makes a lot of sense to me
before we end i'd like to ask you the
same three questions i ask everyone who
joins me are you up for that
i'm ready
all right question number one if you
were to capture the best communication
advice you ever received as a five to
seven word presentation slide title what
would it be
i'm not sure i can keep it to five to
seven words but i think you can get
close okay um
worry about being right at the end of
the meeting not at the beginning of the
meeting um
tell me more but i like that a lot i'll
let you have the extra words
well
i think when it comes to leadership
listening is more important than talking
when you're leading a group of people
or when you're meeting with a group of
stakeholders
before you
articulate your view
probably better to listen to other
people's views if you're leading a team
of people and you're in an authority
role if you lead with what you think you
can bet your bottom dollar that people
will echo that i used to watch president
bush first president bush in cabinet
meetings he never showed his cards when
he was talking about a policy issue he
would always make the cabinet talk about
what their views were
and then he would go back to the oval
office and he'd make a decision
if he had said well i don't think this
policy should be this or that every one
of those people would be saying oh mr
president you're so smart you're so
brilliant that's just the nature of
things but i think the point of it is
listen first talk next
yes words to to live by for sure
let me ask you question two
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
uh i'll give you i'll give you two
gandhi uh-huh and lincoln
okay
because
he was able to
uh inspire
a movement of hundreds of millions of
people
against colonialism in india and he did
it largely in in large ways through
communicating through his
book about
seeking independence
and then speaking and writing
essays
and lincoln
you know who i think had he been able to
serve out his second term i think we
would live in a different country today
all you have to do is read his second
inaugural address about with malice
towards none and charity for all it's a
beautiful address yes and he did it in
so few words just like the gettysburg
address
that
it was so powerful
that he was able to capture what i think
was a a hopeful
vision of what this country could be
absolutely two two wonderful
communicators who did amazing things for
this this world
last question
what are the three ingredients the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe
okay i'll be
too cute by half here
context context context
knowing the
contextual environment of
your circumstance whether it's a crisis
whether it's your reputation
whether it's your brand
knowing having a really rigorous
understanding of the contextual
environment
is the foundation of coming up with
effective strategies
and
achieving your organizational
organization's goals
context is absolutely critical
as were the topics that we discussed
today david i can think of no one better
to help us understand how to communicate
in the times we live in than someone
like yourself who has experience in both
crisis management and crisis
communication as well as political
communication thank you so much for your
time for your insight in for your advice
thanks matt
thank you for listening to think fast
talk smart the podcast to learn more go
to gsb.stanford.edu
please download other episodes wherever
you find your podcasts